jetzt haben einige reininterpretiert das
dadurch dass das so lange gedauert hat
bis dann die listen da waren bzw
das gesundheitsamt er nachts
reinmarschieren musste und sich das
selber holen musste so hat es das
gesundheitsamt dargestellt das ist da
möglicherweise im verdacht illegaler
beschäftigung teilen sie diesen verdacht
also der muss aufgeklärt werden
deshalb haben wir gesagt wir gehen nicht
nur mit den arbeitsschutz behörden der
länder rein und ich habe schon übrigens
vor diesen vorfällen die
landesarbeitsminister ganz am beginn der
pandemie aufgefordert weil wir wussten
das ist ein sensibler bereich macht
kontrollen
wir gehen jetzt mit dem zoll noch nach
der zoll ist eine bundesbehörde die in
der schwarzarbeit kontrolle tätig sind
und wenn es hinweise gibt auf illegale
beschäftigung dann werden die das
verursacht haben an dieser stelle auch
zur verantwortung gezogen werden wir
werden aufräumen
[Musik]